hello we're glad you've joined us for
the
webinar demonics micro brain 3d assay
ready plates as a human iPS sea based
neural spheroid platform for
high-throughput drug screening today's
educational web seminar is presented by
labyrinth the leading scientific social
networking website and provider of
virtual events and webinars advancing
scientific collaboration and learning
it's brought to you by molecular devices
one of the world's leading providers of
high-performance bio analytical
instrumentation software and consumables
and is dedicated to helping customers
unravel the complexity of biological
systems let's get started you can pose
questions to the speaker during the
presentation while they're fresh in your
mind to do so simply type them into the
drop-down box located on the far left of
your screen labeled ask a question then
click on the send button questions will
be answered after the presentation to
enlarge the window click on the arrows
at the top right hand corner of the
presentation window if you experience
technical problems seeing or hearing the
presentation just click on the support
tab found at the top right of the
presentation window or report your
problem by typing it into the answer
question box located on the far left of
your screen this is an educational
webinar and thus offers free continuing
education credits please click on the
continuing education credits tab located
at the top right of the presentation
window and follow the process to
obtaining your credits I would like to
introduce Grisha chandi senior
production manager high content
screening solutions at molecular devices
and he will be moderating this session
thank you very much I wanted to just do
a quick review of the agenda I will
introduce the technology is used in the
seminar today and hosts the Q&A session
at the end are first because cassiano
Karamu lead scientists at stem onyx
who's going to talk about the
development of the 3d human cortical
spheroid platform for high homogeneity
and functional functionality for
high-throughput and icon and screening
so he's going to talk about how he
developed this tool then we're going to
transition over to Oksana Steranko who
is a senior research scientist here at
NASA devices we're going to talk about
the application of this microbe brain 3d
model to a high-throughput high content
toxicity and calcium oscillation assay
so I'm going to transition over and talk
to you about that - technology that two
or three technologies used in this
presentation the first is talking about
automated imaging and you can do imaging
on a conventional microscope and there's
a manual process of putting your samples
on the slide putting a microscope taking
a picture and then trying to figure out
how to make measurements of that of that
picture and that usually takes you hours
with the image express system and haikon
and screening you can move those assays
into multi-level plates or slides but
multiple places what we talking about
today put it into the system
acquire a variety of data types
automatically turn those images into
numbers and then try to make sense of
the data we've collected
and that workflow takes minutes rather
than hours
the complete solution of automated
imaging is require those data those
images convert those images into
something that can be segmented by
automatically by software make these
multi parameter measurements and then
make sense of the data or do curve fits
and so that that's the third offering
through medical devices the other
technology that's being used on in
today's talk is a high throughput
kinetic screen so you put your samples
and plates
you put into the flipper system you get
you add compound you get tracings from
all the wells at the same time and you
analyze that data and try to make sense
of that data now these two solutions
have been combined with the products
from Steam Onix where they have going to
talk about their ipsp derived micro
brain 3d micro brain model and that's
that's one example of it and a blow-up
of what looks like inside and I've taken
the product and put it through a variety
of technologies including the slipper
and image express micro which are these
high-throughput screening devices so on
that note I would like to turn the
presentation over to cassiano who can
tell you about developing this reading
the three human coracle of platform
thank you very much bishop for the
introduction and thank you everyone
aligned today for joining online today
I'll be talking about our latest
development that the 3d model court call
destroyed platform for how to to and
high content screening
so as demonic are our expertise is in
human iPS derive a new role in cardiac
platforms we focus on adapting the
platform for hydraboost screening and
producing as they ready solutions to
accelerate drugs discover so basically
the customer received the plate ready to
go to the assay the cells that are
already plated or in the case of the 3d
you have this Verizon suspension for
this assays I'll be focusing my talk
today on the neuro platforms that you
call microgram more specifically micro
brain at 3d so one of the main
challenges in neuroscience research and
drug development is to find the best
model to answer your question this
figure here summarized the main models
for neuroscience research differ from
low complexity such as silver models in
vitro to high complex but Lothrop ooh
such as animal models or human for
post-mortem brains given the ethical
barriers with the animal models in vivo
and this course the variability of
post-mortem human brains thanks have
relied mostly in vitro models such as
silver models and organized
with the advent of the human pluripotent
stem cells science now has access to any
human tissue in vitro the challenge
though is to find a model that
recapitulate the key aspects of the
tissue or the disease in vitro more
recent research have focus on the
developed up 3d models which more
closely resemble the human brain for
example however then some challenges to
persist and that between these
challenges Part III models they make the
three main ones are one how reproducible
the assay is - how accurate it
recapitulate indeed through what you
observe in vivo and finally how it
scalable this is so here it's the one
could decide to tackle this this problem
developing a new platform that's called
a microplane 3d so one of the main
features of the micro brain 3d is that
this is the right for single donor IPS
line so both are ostracizing neuron that
is composed these platforms derive from
a single cell line this platform is
composed of a cope with a balanced
amount of astrocytes in your try to
start one-to-one ratio of astrocytes in
Europe and they display key neuronal and
astrocytes markers who also deserve it
spontaneous synchronized activity over
time and so this is the sign of maturity
of decision and connectivity between
these neurons and finally with develop a
platform that amenable for high content
screening so all the platforms that
offer right now under 384-well format on
the left here can observe one cry
section of this micro brain or - one of
these fears and highlight the neurons in
green as they stand for map - and the
astrocytes in red as distinct for just
18
one of the first things that we decide
when we started to derive high-low
machines by the form was to derive
platforms at the high Lama James in size
we'll talk about the 3d there is a lot
of variability that and the system and
one of them hardest to control the size
of the steroids
so we with with tackle these problems
offering 384-well plate with one thread
per well and each steroid is highly
machines in size between them so across
the plate there's a lot of consistent in
size they the range of business cards
are around six hundred micrometers so
we're not too big so there is no high
pocket observe in the center and they're
not too small so they can we can
recalculate minutes the features of the
human brain when we receive this
384-well plate you are able to culture
per week so here is just represented as
not shot of the whole 284 well plate we
capture this image using the image and
express microcon focal from a Lacroix
device you can see one of these roids
highlight on the on the right and on the
bottle here is the maximum minimum
representation the graph for the columns
of the death rate for wall so there's 24
columns in the 3d photo place and you
can see how compact it is this
distribution of the size of these
asperities
of course when we're talking about the
three deals one of the main questions
that you have it is how you can
translate everything that or all the
assets that you have in 2d to 3d so it's
very easy to do common assessing to the
likely Emily staining but in 3d adds
some complexities that a lot of
resources are afraid of incorporating
their pipeline we decide to tackle this
problem doing and developing simple acid
or translate simple acids to the 3d
platformer so one of the first one was
multimodal staining so as highlight here
this is a commonly Munna staining with
4% PFA done in suspension we use the
image Express micro called focal
microscope to capture the image so this
disease Tec is the projection of a
cystic but all they stain was done in
suspension without the use of any
special regions is just a regulary
mano-a-mano regions that we have in the
lab
moreover the capture of these images are
also done a suspension so we don't need
to mobilize or Christ action video
steroids to capture some relevant in
information from this platform what
they're going to show now is the video
of this this platform now also capture
to the image Express confocal the
time-lapse of the cows inoculation
in this lead you can observe the
spontaneous Claussen activity present in
micro brain 3d it was capture used an
image express micro control quad 50
frames per second both the images
correspond to the same series before the
only difference between them being the
color profile this is done to better
visualize this caution oscillation
that's happened
as you observe in the video you could
see that there was synchronous active or
synchronous oscillation of this is
varied over time when you measure the
regions of interest of the destroyed you
can see that several cell bodies in the
Detroit presents this neuron also but
presently as activity of thousand
oscillation moreover they're
synchronized over time so there is the
synchronous signal of these tossin
oscillations that's being captured and
in 3d we decide to ask if they stead of
using a low through pool microscope like
on confocal better imaging one through
at a time if you could capture the
oscillations that you observe you are
more hyper profession and the use of is
the flipper from will acquire device
but using the flipper now we can capture
the oscillations of this calcium that we
observe in the 3d in real time for the
whole 384-well plate at the same time
here highlights on the left is worn well
and you can see the oscillation over
time so the change in fluorescence over
time visitors recording made at
viewpoint five frames per second for ten
minutes and you can see that from times
to times it has this visual solution
moreover when we investigate the whole
plate all the wells that have is really
present these active Rizzoli these
active is very homogeneous between the
different world and between different
blades we decide to test if there's
activity correlated with
electrophysiology so it test it would
place some of the Detroit and multi
electrode arrays and we obtain and
they'll observe a lot of these
oscillations happen on the molecular
ways as well
so this correlator for the number of
oscillations that we measure new flipper
so what we are observing in flipper when
you see these oscillations happen on the
on the calcium what we observe is this
massive increase signal that is going
through the holy spirit means
connectivity we have a time of
maturation that this signal start to
happen it is a series but when they
start we observe an all across the whole
plate is to 84 and moreover very
homogeneous between the different wells
of course if you're talking about the
neurons are talking about cells that
respond to a lot of chemicals especially
little more later so I decide to test is
what you have is this signal set to
observe and flipper can be modulated
with some and no neuronal de laters our
culture is composed mainly of the
glutamatergic and Governor on this is a
cortical differentiation towards this
this sulfate so on this first slide and
highlight some of the glutamatergic
modulators so we have glutamatergic
agonist like the connect as and the
clinic as you can observe that it
increases the oscillation what so what
is shown here in the bar graphs this is
the peak frequency or the oscillations
were to observe relative to they control
that you have so a hundred percent means
no change in the oscillation pattern and
less than hundred percent means that
were decreasing the number of
oscillation will represent that signal
more than a hundred percent means that
we're increasing the number of solution
or accelerating the oscillations pattern
the clinic has just do just that as it's
expected flow on agony after the
glutamatergic system but i also start to
repress after some time we believe that
at that point you start to reach excited
proxy study show this day stimulus is
the similar to the came a gas is being
too much instead of having a continuous
acceleration or having a red repression
because you have inducing excited proxy
city the the same little modulation was
observed with the glutamatergic
antagonist so we have a several classes
antagonists represented here at CN a key
acts any bgx DX and indicator one and
all them reduced these active reducible
oscillations in a dose-dependent manner
so more concentrated and more the
reduction that you observe our systems
also composed of the GABAergic neurons
so we decide to test if they can have
also got very regulation there with us
the GABA agonist per person and Massimo
so these are compounds we are going to
potentiate the gaba system that the
inhibitor system
want to a petition that you are reducing
the number of oscillations we were able
to capture that I'll sing adults
dependent manner there is a lot of
interest of a platform for seizure
approach to project and we decide to
test if you know scissors and compound
can it use some change in this platform
so it has the form in pyridine unknown
citizen compound and also induce
increase in the oscillation over a
dose-dependent
in a dose-dependent manner as well
so of course many many of our customers
and people that collaborate with us they
are not used to these readings of in the
flipper this is spontaneous readings in
flipper especially in 3d so it's hard to
correlate between multiple platforms how
you use here the flipper image Express
confocal and they multi electrode arrays
to see if the changes where to observe
the platforms are similar
Moochie electrode arrays is now a
standard for electrophysiology and a lot
of people understand quite easily what
what are the change there so here on the
border can see they'd control treated
and forming paradigm that the decisions
any compound and you can see that there
are clear chains in the profile and a
pattern of activation of these neurons
but these changes are also observed in
the flipper so on the top here you have
the very controlled assimilate control
versus the form in the period I created
our wells and you can see the change in
pattern so there is a increase in the
frequency of this oscillation similar to
what to observe in a mooch electrode
arrays finally you also deserve that in
the image express confocal so email
express now we are doing a high
resolution imaging time-lapse of this of
the sculptures using the confocal
microscopy and one of the beautiful use
an image express and flippers that you
can use back to back this particular
experiment we use the same shape control
that you imagine flipper right after
measure the whole plate and slipper you
can go to the English express and do a
high resolution only of that steroids
that have interest for example there is
a modulation for specific modulations
that have particular interest it can
record that using now the image Express
confocal to see these oscillations and
to confirm the data you have been once
you have this powerful platforming house
inside to use in several projects or
case studies here this is just to
mention some of the example some
examples that's how you are using
in-house here for example for assay
development disease modeling using
especially for modeling and near
developer disorders we start with
hindering
we also do in for drug discovery or we
have a customer that we are doing it
with some very scary for a clabsi drug
discover for libraries compound's that
came motivated in a persistent who also
did recent with the collaboration -
screen of the low pipe library that the
library of 1,280 compounds and you'll
find very interesting heats and a lot of
produces variability between the
response for well to all from the
replicate so that's what really nice
finally we will also use them for safety
for my college and cooks college so I'm
going to show one example of mill tox
screen for a drug that dates to treat
Zika infection and Oksana following my
presentation also going to show some
examples of that of collaboration that's
going to be denied for molecular device
about environment toxins are in the
doctor sack
so Zika virus have been in the media for
some time there was a lot of attraction
worldwide especially because of the
consequence so it was causing especially
pregnant women some birth to the fact it
was a new virus and then sigh in the
ways that the infection in new locations
and especially in Brazil it hit hard
with a lot of people get in fact the
vector there is endemic so was it spread
really fast in Brazil and although there
was a lot of effort from the side to
community
to speed up the drug development there
were no current vaccines that available
or effective medications for Zika virus
but one of the approaches that the
science decide to take it is to repose
drugs that already FDA approves I said a
fear is higher the pipeline from zero
and develop new compounds let the screen
the libraries compounds get a read
approved by the FDA so you can report
these compounds and put to the clinic
much faster than a new compound that's
need to test for 4/5 caches one of the
problems though was to intensify
compounds that were not only food but
safe to use specially pregnant women so
this is a very practical case that if
you are using a compound as prophylaxis
to avoid any consequences of the Zika
virus we need to make sure that that
compound safe so we need to make sure
that a not induced in Texas especially
the central nervous system so we decided
to test that with the platform that we
have in-house the first test that you
did was a talk to profile cell viability
profile this we use a two different
stage of your cell lines we use I stage
that was presenter stage that we call
here any pcs or nurse fears and you use
also a more mature stage that's were
more mature neurons and we call Micro
brain 2d on micro brain 3d so have the
two platforms in 2d and 3d you decide to
test both of them to see how they ask us
between the two platforms and how they
differ and there was a lot of
correlation between the two platforms so
now we're very pleasing to observe that
you can mimic refined about to have an
in 3d
into the in the 3d environment
especially using techniques that are
very common in the industry especially
for tops College the only difference
between the two is that he study fused
the cell title or Omega for the 2d used
itself as a global America 3d for the 3d
platform and you can use any plate
reader to read this essay in this case
you use it the spectrum axis from
molecular device to do this readings one
thing that was worth clear it is there
is a lot of compounds that induce
success especially at high doses so what
we're seeing here is a heat map of the
cell viability and more gold means that
less of viability more blue means a
hundred percent pebbles so no change in
the cell viability and a range of
concentration of five different
concentrations of compounds from 10
micromolar to 0.01 micro molar and you
can see that and the highest
concentration special in the presenter
stage that the NPC's in the Inner Sphere
there is a lot of toxicity of this
compound not surprising mean of this
compounds that are being repurposed to
Zika there were approved for cancer at
treatment and especially targeted cell
cycle of the of the cells and for
progenitor stage the south side is
really crucially important for for that
cell line so that's why we believe that
to observe so much toxicity at the
presenter stage but not too much
toxicity in more mature stage or if you
want to have more pause my tadka neurons
one thing to keep in mind though is that
if you're using these in pregnant women
h be aware that that can influence the
set of developments as well so we need
to avoid this compensating incur too
must exist at that stage we decide to
select some of the compounds that you
consider safe so the compounds that
didn't use much toxicity to test in a
functional level to see if you even
though they don't have a cell viability
drop if you dare induce a functional
change on this on these cell lines
we again use both platforms micro brain
should be in micro brain 3d but now we
use the sleeper touch again so is a more
high school screening as
compounds the difference between the 2d
and 3d the waiver to do is that usually
when we use the micro brain 2d you're
induced to response the glutamatergic
agonist so you induce that artificial
response with the glutamate is a
compound that we stimulate the cells and
this state are using the glutamate
itself or the clinic ask and what will
one observe is that on that stimulation
when you hit with the compound compounds
that after the pretreatment with this
compound that were considered safe in
the saw viability if you they induce any
change from the control or the vague
freedom cells and we did observe three
compounds that didn't use some change in
fact okay so there were although they
did induce too much salt toxicity they
didn't use a functional toxicity that
could be observed on the flipper
moreover when we test on the macro grain
3d because the macro entity has this
spontaneous even we don't need to induce
that response or what we are doing here
to just measure the spontaneous signal
that we observe and with pretreated
physical bonds to measure if there is
any interference of that surprising on
we did find similar results have
wonderful that you did but also found
that there is a cup of compound that
didn't use change in the big freakin
sore in the figures of that pigs
compared to to the macro brain
2d that could not capture that
difference so basically micro brain
should be we should induce the response
we didn't capture change that could
observe the micro brain 3d with a
spontaneous oscillation so there was a
cup of compounds especially the ones
highlight here pure metal 9 and Apollo
knows it's wrong you can see that the
highest concentrations there is a
changes in the considerable change to
the control compared and compared to the
controls a while the micro going to the
induces response didn't deserve that
moreover you also found a compounds that
were a relative safe like Enriquez and
that's wonderful it was highly coded for
treatment of the Zika virus finally
decides to see if you
can measure this difference where to
observe on the 3d sound micro grain 3d
using the flipper I'll also capture in
the electrophysiology standpoint and
you're really pleasant to see that this
compound that we're safe in the
microgram 3d like a den where Kisan
still in induced any considerable change
in several parameters of a to measure
using a micro brain to the emu
collective array so this is
electrophysiology on the on the on the
left so changes here on the
electrophysiology are or towards less
frequent that's going to be more white
or more frequent that's going to be red
so we're looking for compounds better
maintain this hit map close to blue so
that's why the Cointreau is the first
one and you can see the depth of my sin
and the Rickerson
also keep that powder that's close the
remember to the control but all the
other compounds that were consider safe
we we can see a safe of the cell
viability you can see that there is a
functional toxicity moreover you are
able to capture that function of
toxicity using the micro brain 3d so the
main difference here between the mu CH
electrode arrays and the micro grain 3d
is because the to prove the micro brain
3d being a three to four world is much
higher especially in combination to the
flipper you can also see every time that
you say receive this change you can now
take this change that to observe the
flipper take this plate and measure how
more high-resolution using the image
express confocal so you can even have a
high resolution of that signal that is
is inducing some change that the things
that are important so overall we think
that our platform is is very capable to
answer very complex questions like this
one and investigate a third programmatic
problem like the Zika virus infection a
very fast way especially in combination
of the within platforms for molecular
device
so in summary for this webinar what I
hope that I show you today with that the
microphone 3d is aneroid right platform
couple of mature court corners and
ostracized
so they present highly consistent
functional signal between the different
worlds and making it suitable for - Pugh
is creating the neural networks
responsible to Navitus model errors and
we don't need to activate that and that
signal is it spontaneous sequence that
arise from the front of the development
is 3d so that you can model a to a few
compounds later on and we can use this
platform to investigators that can be
applied at different levels so
omona staining as I show cell viability
as I show the survivability and finally
functional that's one of the key aspects
this platform to be used to
would like to end my talk just think
today's demonics teen and leave and
here's some contact information for more
for more information and the way that
they're going to pass you Oxana that
going to cut you know what some shows
the most exciting finds that you have
with a collaboration that you have
molecular device thank you very much
thank you so much for your introduction
so this is Oksana Steranko i am senior
scientist at molecular devices so i will
be talking about evaluation of neuronal
toxicity using stem cell derived
neuronal 3d cultures so this is increase
in needs on using complex and
biologically relevant more predictive
cell based assays to screen and evaluate
compounds with potential for native
activities the current methods for neuro
toxic evaluation rely mostly on animal
models which have their limitation
related to throughput cost and relevance
to human data so there is a pressing
need for the development of
multi-dimensional screening strategies
that would provide improved productivity
and also allow to facilitate
prioritization of chemicals for
invitations there is also very important
is requirement for essays to be
compatible with the high throughput
screening so the goal of present study
was to evaluate feasibility of micro
brain 3d mcsneer occurs for native
exceeded screening also to optimize
phenotypic readout for quantitative
compound responses and still the
selected set of known neuro toxic
compounds we used first kinetic
fluorescence imaging on the flipper or
imaging system to measure patterns and
frequencies of the culture population
continuous insulation of nero steroids
were monitored by changes in interest
rate or calcium levels discussed
insensitive dice here you can see
control steroids calcium escalation
he used the si for optimized for high
throughput screening in the 3d for well
plates in a typical experiment we
received triplet asteroid's from steam
onyx then we cultured them for four days
and then traded with compounds in this
example you can see the screen shot from
the 384-well plate on a flipper
recordings are done for 10 minutes you
can see control samples and also sampled
created with different concentration of
drugs each 12 of the 384 plates contain
symbols uniformly sized steroids and
generated highly consistent performance
across the wells and plays needle
steroids were exposed to compounds in
concentration response for either 60
minutes or 24 hours
the essay allows phenotypic
characterization of escalation profiles
by using multi parametric analysis that
include the escalation rate the
frequency the amplitude decrease
distance between Peaks as well as tick
rate and decay times and perform
irregularities the analysis is done
using screen works stick pro software
using fatigue analysis
here represent example of traces of
several new directive reference
compounds that includes non drugs like
leader cane lamotrigine dilantin and
haloperidol you can see dramatic changes
in a bit in a big frequency you can see
decrease in a frequency and also
increase in spacing and irregularity
also his best extent of knowledge Nero
toxic compounds included Mathilde
Mercury's return on MPT and barbarian
chloride they also observed those
dependent changes in air adults
including decrease in epic raid
amplitude also changes in spacing and
pick this
you
changes in epic frequency and amplitude
were also absorbed with compounds with
unknown mode of action including flame
retardants and pesticides
in addition to calcium flux sa high
content imaging methods very used to
gain additional information about
morphology and viability to the sphere
image using automated control imaging
system the image expressed micro
conforto with either 10x or 20x
objective the methods for imaging
steroids were previously described but
typically this stack of four from 10 to
20 images taken separated by 5 to 10
micron starting from the bottom of the
well and moving up all individual images
can be saved and used for 3d analysis or
analysis can be done using 2d projection
image
here you can see steroids stain for
cytotoxicity assessment steadily
sustained
Wisconsin a.m. for viability stain might
attract er orange for mitochondria
potential and nuclear dye stain first
the analysis for imaging results outputs
were generated using custom model editor
the analysis first find steroids as a
object and then secondly defines number
of light cells which identified by
presence of calcium a.m. signal and then
sort identifies number of cells with
intact mitochondria stained stained by
my detector orange death cells would be
identified by absence or decrease of
contain a.m. signal so here you can see
the masks for steroids
also mask for positive cells live cells
stained with red and negative nuclear
stain in blue
so as you can see here the control
steroid has a strong staining for
contain a.m. and my tracker orange and
the one which has decreased variability
have decreased number of live cells and
you can quantitate all these changes
in the present studies we characterize
kinetic and also confer call Imogen
medals that compatible with automated
instruments and demonstrated the
potential utility of human IPSC derived
3d neuronal steroids for toxicity
screening
here you can see a list of scientific
descriptors used for neurotoxicity
evaluation multi parameter analysis
delivers informative readouts that
enable screening for effects of test
compounds on neuronal activity and also
on cell morphology and viability
if estimated the percent of variability
for those videos use videos control well
on same place or different place just
device for samples and calculated the
percent of variability so for different
results this percent of variability
presented here for 60 minutes or for 24
hours
you
as a next step we use the matter to
evaluate
Texas to the effects of compounds from a
library of 91 compounds received from
national sex ecology program the library
contains representative examples from
different classes of chemicals including
pharmaceutical drugs pesticides flame
retardants and poly aromatic
hydrocarbons this work is currently in
progress here you can see a heat map of
the responses for the degrade where blue
corresponds to decrease in secret and
red correspond to increase in population
rate you can see this number of
compounds called significant changes in
the secret and also in other results
in this example for a member of
pesticides
you can see how compounds can be ranked
for their potential toxic effect in the
bottom you can see highly toxic
compounds like fur material or builder
material and in the top you can see
compounds with less known toxicities
we can calculate effective concentration
of the compound effect for different
readouts and then we can run compounds
for their potential narrow toxic hazard
and this graph you can see effective
concentrations for different readouts so
the smallest one presented and as a
black triangle there is effective
concentration for correspondent
viability effects so this information
can be used for plugins potentially
toxic compounds and for prioritization
of those four other tests this method is
very suitable for screening of multiple
chemicals in the five throughput format
so in a summary they were able to
demonstrate that nearest arrow is
responsible for neurotoxic effect and
can be used for evaluation of the
electricity of various compounds and
it's very important that si is amenable
for high-throughput as a format and can
enable customers to the screening of
multiple compounds
I would like to acknowledge our
collaborators from the National
Institute of Environmental Health
Sciences for providing this set of
compounds for testing and also
collaborators from demonics and my
co-workers from molecular devices thank
you so much for your attention please
follow up with aggression
Thank You cassiano car Mayo and Oksana
Siringo for your presentation
a quick reminder for our audience on how
to submit questions simply type them
into the drop down box located on the
far left to your presentation window
labeled ask a question and click on the
send button Cassiano and Oksana will
answer as many of your questions as time
permits
Krisha you may now begin the Q&A
hi thanks oksanen Cassiano nice talks we
have a number of questions for Cassiano
it's demonic about your body cell models
so what you know how did you mention
exactly how your cell lines are derived
and and the benefits of the co-culture
system and whether they come from a
single cell source or not how does that
work what are the benefits of that
the expiration so regarding that
question what to do have just to to
highlight some of some of the features
of the product it is that you have both
- suicides and the neurons that
incorporate the microgravity they're
derived from the same cell source so the
for the same patient so we have a one
cell line that derive both of them so
it's it's a co differentiation we don't
defend them separate this is coded for
entity in this variety the reason for
that is to help the maturation the
crosstalk between these both cell types
and we we started with the same IPS cell
line source you can start with disease
line or can start with control so light
warfare right now control so lines or we
have no port pole in the future possible
disease two lines regard the difference
between the 2d and 3d what we have
observed in India to here is that there
is a faster maturation in 3d regard and
compared to the 2d so this is not only
gene expression and Amon staining but
also functional so we haven't observed a
lot of electrophysiology activity on the
3d with speed up of his maturation
compared with the 2d micro brain so I
think you just touched on to other
questions in the list somebody asked the
question about whether you can get
patient-derived microbial model and you
sort of hinted that do you want to talk
a little bit more about the home yes at
the moment I will have we're offering
the control cell line so this is a known
disease online we do have a cell bank
with the disease cell lines have a
couple times that we're starting we we
can offer as a custom project in the
future this is two lines for this for
more information I would advise that the
guys have been contacted for the contact
that I share that was David and Ryan
from schematics but they can answer that
question the zone okay and then you
mention a little bit about 2d and 3d
what's the real application difference
being micro Dane 3d product and a 2d
culture okay so besides the advantage of
the 3d readily
maturation so we have a faster
maturation and on the 3do compared to
the 2d the minute event is the fact that
you have a spontaneous oscillation on
this and it's very machines between the
well so we do observe spontaneous
relation on 2d as well but maybe because
of the layer of cells that's a little
bit more compact there is more variation
from well throughout the 384-well format
why on the micro brain 3d when use the
trail for Wells there is a much less
variation because Oxana point a little
bit of this activity or variation
between the world and especially the
direct response as well there is a lot
of correlation between the drugs
response and less variation on that okay
how do how do people obtain the micro
printed product and there's any
difference between people in North
America versus international yeah at the
moment these are all pre plated products
so which ship the cells the cells ready
to go basically with ship in hibernation
media so the only requirement it is that
you recommend is that there is a media
change when we receive the cells these
are free-floating mr. IDEs so there is
some special requirements to how to do
they need a change we have advisors ifu
and for for all the steps and vision
protocols for all the steps for how to
do this video change performing to me
the change we do recommend that there is
a at least one week of acclamation in
the lab before you use the cells but we
already receive the cells ready to go
don't need to talk or don't need to to
prepare yourselves with the plate
already have the cells pre plating and
let you go for pro dances okay there's a
question for Oksana this is a question
for kana which readouts are the most
reliable to quantify the concentration
response of X so you tried
nice different readouts and while all of
them kind of useful to get more
description of the phenotypes and
phenotypic responses so you find that
some of them have lower variability and
some of them have higher variability so
the example of one which relatively
lower variability and more high
confidence is a peak rate and also the
amplitude and peak with some other have
fir greater variability either this
interval between wells or between plates
and some of them are decay time or
distance between Peaks okay thank you
there's two questions for Cassandra here
have you tried the micro brain 3d in
other formats like microfluidic or organ
and chip devices so we have not at the
moment at the moment we have a only
donated 384 well format free-floating
what we're trying to do is in the future
offer products that incorporate even
more cell types in this micro brain 3d
like for example microglia and the BBB
layer so the blood-brain barrier and
have you done any work to examine the
excitatory to inhibitory neurons and if
you did so how do you evaluate them
so the ratio that to have in our on
their micro branch we D is usually a to
9% of kilometers to 10 to 20 percent of
grabbers that been said it's real hard
to do amanhã stain is for quantification
on these 3d platforms at least for the
Holy Spirit we can do in the end the
layers as a on the surface or in the
some layers as I showed and the Emunah
staining we're working with some
protocols to date abilify or two prior
five is sterilized and be able to image
through the Holy Spirit in 3d we have
quantify these or using microgreen 2d
that's the same
progenitor cells that used the
derivation they were defense that grow
then in 3d in the micro brain 3d and the
ratio is roughly 80 to 90 percent
recruiter meterics 10 to 20% of
GABAergic we showed them similar tenets
in gene expression profile as well
what we hope to do in the future is do
more single-cell gene sequence that can
help you to answer these questions all
the population by having a micro brain
3d come on ask questions so much of
opinion questions or ask asean a person
and Oksana can also answer up to you now
do you think this technology will help
reduce and replace the use of animals
and research in toxicology testing so
this was one of the our main hope Sandra
nice one of the the things that to talk
the most the fact that we can
recapitulate better some of the human
brain physiology the fact that you have
this spontaneous oscillation we Tru
believe that you can replace in the
future animal animal model who in the
main reasons because now you are working
with a human cells instead of an animal
cells in theater right so it can
recuperate some things that is really
hard to recapitulate in human animals or
cannot model in human animals because of
the uniqueness of the human neurons of
the human brain but now may be able to
relate that in the animal model and I
thought your opinion because you've been
working quite a lot on a number of
complex models or on toxicology what's
your opinion I believe this is very
important to develop systems which would
allow to test different toxic compounds
in a high-throughput scale and so there
are millions of compounds in environment
there are kind of hundreds of developing
drugs on the market so to test them all
comprehensively it's a very big effort
and so development of essays which is
amenable for high-throughput screening
is extremely important and by doing that
you can not only include more compounds
for testing but also
you can prioritize those for further
testing
thanks Oksana question for cassiano over
what culture times that you found your
data to be stable for example
experiments only on post 810 or expense
any day between plating day and 10 to 40
so some stability questions so we do
recommend up to the customers when to
receive the the macro brain 3d that they
stick to the same timeframe this is a
product that is still in development and
no developments to present some captures
from the other development so over time
what you observe is acceleration of the
frequent so there is a change in the
frequency over time that's why when we
receive the product you read targeted
window that is more suitable for for
response for neuromodulators so when you
receive the product these are already
mature for some time in your hands and
they usually target on eight weeks to
ten weeks for use of business roids
there is a cup of customers that asked
if they could go longer and what's going
to be effect of that if they could mimic
like instead of weeks months in vitro
who have done some extensive culture in
vitro just to validate the product for
for up to 25 weeks and what we observe
was an acceleration of this this
frequency so meaning that there is also
a more maturity more a gene expression
being of the neurotransmitters of the
human brain neurotransmitters there but
we stick mostly to the winds of 8 to 10
weeks I haven't seen a lot of
reproducibility between that if for any
particular reason you want to use a
later time point that can be done as
well as you have also custom asked for
earth time points you want to mimic
various steps of neurodevelopment as
well in the past so that can can be also
as a custom product matures yeah so
let's relate to another question about
another Costas equation this is about
the purchase of plates today versus next
month so you talked about post plating
consistency and what about like batch
you know delivery to delivery
consistency we we do deserve a lot of
consistency between des between
different place we have a quality
control for some known and
neuromodulators I bet he used to
validate our batch and there is a lot of
consistence between that so so it not
only between the wells or between the
placement from the same batch but also
between different bags you do observe a
lot of consistent what you do recommend
what I already highlight it is to use to
the same time point for different ones
so we do not recommend for example use
on eight weeks at some point and 16
weeks and data point so there is some
some room for change on that product in
the ways that there is a continuous
development of that product in theater
right so you want to speak as you do
your planer experiments with the neurons
are louder so types usually we stick for
one specific time point we recommend to
do the same and if you do that there is
a lot of consistence between the
products any example of mimicking a
neurodegenerative disease example
chronic low concentration treatment with
compounds like glutamate so you have it
I guess that looks like a person wants
to know if you keep the compound in
there yeah we we have not yet in a much
work for in the liver of the disease or
neurodegenerative disease we have were
starting some work in one new developer
disease once I wanted to have here for
for a retina we will hope to offer offer
in the future based or for in the
neurodegenerative regard we we did some
work for seizures and compounds as a
highlight in the presentation with you
in the primary steps of modern days in
day 2 of this model and I'll tell you
haven't done any chronic long-term
treatment with compounds either right
yes this is very interesting aspects
would be for future development yeah
okay I looking the number of questions
are winding down please continue to
submit questions we'll hang on here for
one more minute if there aren't any
questions and
you
you
you
you
well if there are no more questions I
would like to once again think casiano
cameo and Oksana serenka for their
presentation before we go I'd like to
thank the audience for joining us today
and for their interesting questions just
to reminder any questions we did not
have time for today will be addressed by
the speaker via the contact information
you provided at the time of the
registration this webcast can be viewed
on-demand through September of 2018
laborat swill alert you via email when
it's available for replay we encourage
you to share that email with your
colleagues who may have missed today's
live event until next time goodbye